das ist wirklich eine schlechte
nachricht der status james webb
weltraumteleskop wird schon wieder
verschoben und der grund ist diesmal
ziemlich beunruhigen das revolutionäre
teleskop funktioniert nicht richtig was
konkret schiefgelaufen ist und welche
konsequenzen es hat jetzt in klicks zum
science fiction herzlich willkommen
das ist wirklich eine sehr schlechte
nachricht der staates absolut
revolutionären james webb
weltraumteleskop es muss schon wieder
verschoben werden
das teleskop wird eine neue stufe der
forscher erreichen wenn es denn endlich
gestartet ist das riesen
weltraumteleskop hat eine achtung
hundertfach bessere auflösung als das
derzeitige rekord weltraumteleskop
hubble das ist wirklich spektakulär das
james webb weltraumteleskop kurz cabrio
s t ist nämlich speziell darauf
vorbereitet leben auf exoplaneten zu
entdecken
anhand des sternenlichts dass durch die
atmosphäre eines solchen planeten zu uns
gelangt kann diese atmosphäre analysiert
werden und das cabrio es kann das mit
ungeahnter perfektion und zog zudem im
infraroten bereich dieser langweilige
bereich dringend besser aus allen teilen
des weltraums zu uns durch gibt es auf
den vom bdst untersuchten planeten leben
hat die atmosphäre eine ganz bestimmte
zusammensetzung und diese kann dann
anhand der bilder perfekt analysiert
werden es ist also ein riesen schritt
bei der suche nach außerirdischem leben
zudem soll es in die zeit kurz nach dem
urknall blicken und die struktur und
entwicklung von galaxien untersuchen
hier könnten bedeutende erkenntnisse zur
dunklen materie und deren existenz oder
eben auch nicht existenz gewonnen werden
und sterne und planetensysteme sollen
näher beobachtet werden durch die
wirklich ungeheuerliche auflösung sind
von dem teleskop wirklich unglaubliche
erkenntnisse und aufnahmen zu erwarten
doch jetzt kann man sagen wann das sein
wird das steht in den sternen
nein ganz so ist es nicht aber das ist
schon ein rückschlag bei einem
stresstest lockerten sich jetzt einige
schrauben und das land darf natürlich
nicht sein
jetzt muss geklärt werden woran es lag
und das problem beseitigt werden damit
dafür genug zeit bleibt wurde der staat
jetzt vom mai 2020 auf den dreißigsten
märz 2021 verschoben dieses datum und
das ist die gute nachrichten soll jetzt
verbindlich sein wir sind gespannt wenn
ihr keine videos dazu und zu allen
anderen themen verpassen wollt dann
endet mich bei whatsapp dann umgeht er
die kaputte am boxi auf youtube und
verpasst kein video
denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir
auch noch vor allen
von neuesten video täglich und
garantiert einfach hier draufklicken und
am besten auch meinen schwesterkanal
klicks um social and media abonnieren da
gibt es das neueste aus der schutzschirm
media welt dafür hier klicken aber nicht
die genau die glocke vergessen wie geht
es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken
alien suche heute beginnt eine neue ära
bis dahin bleibt dran